so i got a good example here we got this
story from business insider anti-vaxxers
storm a new york cheesecake factory in
protest that ends in six arrests that's
the story anti-vaxxer is a funny time
these are basically andy mandate
protests so that's me they showed up to
the cheesecake factory they they're like
they were apparently refused to be
seated so they decided to defeat
themselves is my understanding and then
the manager was like you can't be in
here the police showed up they said
we're not going to leave they were
chanting things like that are they
anti-vaxxed for the first shot the
second shot the the third shot or the
fourth shot because there are actually
yeah there are a lot of people who do
who did take the shot that that don't
want it to be mandated on people and
they're still being called anti-vaxxers
when they took the shot themselves i
think they were four the first not the
second
not the third but the fourth they're
forgotten it totally makes sense but
these are but these are people putting
skin on the line these are people coming
into a restaurant peacefully saying hey
we want some service here the restaurant
comes up to them says hey we have to
comply with this role and this role and
this rule and this world with the
federal government and they said you
know what no no no no no no we're not
going to comply with the government
whims that you demand of us and then
they're like okay we're going to call
the police they call the police the
police carried out these orders and
these decrees by of course but hold on
bureaucrats and they arrested these
people i think there's some there's an
interesting you know sort of middle
ground here watching these videos it was
very reminiscent of watching leftist
protests as well
the protesters did not understand what
they what was going on they were saying
you can't kick us out it's a public
accommodation we're allowed to be here
and it's like bro you can be told to
leave
the police
aren't there because of the vax mandates
they're there because you're trespassing
exactly a private business has a right
to exclude you from business but that's
not the argument that a lot of people on
the left make saying you do have to bake
the cake you do have to provide a
service no matter what so these people
are using the same arguments and a lot
of people are bringing in parallels to
this to what happened in the 1960s with
some of the restaurant sit-ins that
happened then that was fighting against
discrimination and there is a lot of
discrimination a lot of segregation that
deserves to be pushed back that violates
human rights that's being called on by
bureaucrats by big statists who are
violating the most sacred right of all
the right to exist the right to be able
to buy food and water and that's
incredulous and crazy so yeah that
that's where i go to real quick like i
thought that food was an essential
service now maybe you could argue oh
well you're not you don't have a right
to go to cheesecake factory or del
monaco steakhouse or mcdonald's
it's also supermarkets but but well but
in all of the mandates that i've seen
there is a carve out for grocery stores
because i think that they knew that they
would not in some places not in some
places like in canada where they give
the the right for supermarkets
and in australia and in australia
so many friends that are so many friends
that are aussies and that's insane i
think the thing that you mentioned about
like bodily autonomy and like your
individual health care rights it's kind
of funny how the left used to say like
healthcare was a human right and like
your body your choice until now um i get
really annoyed by the people that try to
make the comparison to the hobby lobby
case because i tweeted earlier tonight
that um you know your your employer
should not be able to tell you like what
to put in your body or what to do with
your body especially if it's not a
detriment to your job performance or the
safety of those around you and people
are like oh yeah but what about hobby
lobby and i'm like hobby lobby didn't
tell their employees no you can't take
contra contraceptives they said we are
morally opposed to paying for that yeah
and and then i've also had people
because like i said i'm a homebirth
hippie they're like well your employer
knew you were having a home birth i'm
like the only reason that jeremy bourne
knew i was having a home birth is
because i talk about it all the time and
i try to convince people to do the same
thing and i love being a doula i'm like
but my employer your employer doesn't
know your birth plan your employer
doesn't know what vaccines you're going
to give your kids your employer doesn't
know any of that stuff your insurance
company that your employer subsidizes
does but not the employers and now you
have like kroger grocery stores which
they own ralph's in in california and i
legitimately i'm like i spend thousands
of dollars a month at ralph's i will
find a different grocery store well they
just announced different just for the
audience out there they just announced
that they're going to be cutting away
benefits for their unvaxxed workers and
employees that's the major decision
they're also trying to get into the
florida market and a lot of florida
people are saying hey you don't support
this business and this is the way to do
it so vote with your dollar support the
businesses that that you that support
you that support your individual liberty
your individual freedom but in new york
city a lot of these businesses are told
to obey and go along with the edicts
today five-year-olds have to show their
vax mandate paperwork and their
identification when it comes to in-door
uh stores and businesses that is fault
the people who comply the stores in
business yes absolutely i so wish
um there's a lot of places that are not
complying in la and i don't want to
publicize who they are because i don't
want the health department to come and
knocking but i've heard from a lot of
businesses there and i'm sure it's it's
the same in other places it's like
we're not going to comply it kind of
depends on the enforcement of it right
that's the bottom line because in la i
think for the la county health
department for restaurants that don't
require vax cards and bars and stuff
like that the first fine is a thousand
dollars most people can scrounge up that
money right the second find is like two
the third one is ten and after that you
can lose like all of your licenses and
it's and that is a lot for a business
who maybe still be in the red from the
government shutting them down during
covid to say am i willing to take this
risk but they're willing to take the
risk of violating the ada and the eeoc
they're unaware though this goes back
they're not they're not i've actually
people that are out i called a couple
dozen new york restaurants and
they were just like yup like every every
one of these businesses has to have that
thing on the wall that explains you
can't discriminate in the basement of
medical conditions yeah so i called
these restaurants and one of them i
asked i was like i talked to 26 and i
said would you discriminate against
someone in the midst of medical
conditions they all said yes one of them
i was like so you know my question to
you is like which do you think is worse
like the thousand dollar fine for
violating the executive order or the
potential 250 000 fine for human rights
violations under new york city and state
law and they hung up on me yeah because
they probably do not know and they're
like this thing is on the wall and they
don't understand they're like this guy
this guy's pranking me i think it's
weird that they would know about a
decree like an executive order like
verbatim but they wouldn't know about
their own business really when the media
is like pushing it and touting it and
talking about how important it is and
when you have the mayor and the governor
and the president of the united states
because the people who run these
businesses have to file to get these
things and are sent to them and they
hang them up so like
if they have you ever met somebody that
like works in hr that hangs that up
they're not passing it away businesses
in new york city are not big corporate
collaborates they're small restaurants
it's like it's it's mostly small
businesses
actually the majority of restaurants in
the country are are owned by immigrants
women and and in new york city small
businesses i'm calling and talking to
the managers and the owners yeah and
they know this they know they're
violating the violating the americans
then they've dug their grave right right
so so i'd love to see and they've lost
what is it like 63 there wasn't there's
an article even before this second like
mandate here's here's what we need we
need
a a president who is going to tell this
country
all of these businesses will be
investigated for violations of the equal
employment you know law equal employment
laws uh the americans with disabilities
act because in new york city they
actually are firing people who have like
guillain-barre syndrome yeah this is the
craziest thing to me when they announced
that the vaccine mandate meant that if
you were medically barred from getting
the vaccine you lost your job and i'm
like i'm pretty sure that's illegal
and it is so i want to see some
enforcement you think just because you
run mom and pop's cheeseburger shop you
can break the lawn discriminate against
people no i want to see them find i want
to see them find the maximum penalty for
that yeah i also think that if you're a
guy that or a gal that owns a business
that's going to do that to your employee
at a small business my mom owns and
operates a small business and has for
years and there's a lot of incredible
small business owners out there that
care about their people like you're
probably an [ __ ] boss
before coven if you're willing to fire
somebody during covid for not getting
the job there's a lot of leaving enabled
exactly like and that's another extreme
of like you're a jerk we also have to
understand there's a lot of businesses
that are not complying they're not going
along with this one because they can't
afford to they can't afford extra staff
there's already a staffing shortage uh
and and now they're gonna have to
discriminate against people who will or
will not be able to enter their business
to transact financially with them that's
absolutely crazy this these regulations
these mandates hurt and butcher small
businesses but they allow mega national
corporations to succeed because they
could hire the extra person they could
have the security guard outside and of
course they don't face the full brunt of
the state but again a lot of people in
new york city not complying a lot of
people in manhattan complying brooklyn
not so much and that's why it's also
crazy to see major hospital unions also
a lot of major institutions like amtrak
just totally dropped the vaccine mandate
because they they can't go along with it
because they can't hire enough people to
do the jobs that they need to get done
they were gonna have to shut down train
services delay and they're like we
literally can't so the vaccine mandates
out yeah well amtrak just announced that
a couple months ago by the way that
they're not going
along with it you know there's a there's
like legal defense funds and stuff that
i follow too on social and you are
seeing like small wins you're seeing the
delays and it all it needs to do is
start with the delay and then hopefully
one day it'll go away completely well
there's three judges that are going
against biden's mandate but the biden
administration has plans on the table to
set up a domestic passport system when
it comes to interstate travel where
they're going to be checking vaccine
passports that's some of the plans that
they want to put forward there's nothing
we haven't yet
judicial but this is something that has
already been implemented in australia
yeah absolutely commerce clause anyone
australia australia is about like the
people of australia are some of the uh
not all of them yeah but they're very
very cowardly they're the most compliant
people i've ever met in my entire life
and they're like oh it's okay we'll see
okay like if i do this then they'll
leave me alone if i do this then they'll
leave me alone the united states is like
the trope of the
armed redneck in a tank being like
preemptive attack
like the i love that family guy joke
where um kermit the frog is playing he's
like playing the banjo or whatever and
someone's going through a swamp and
they're like hey can you tell me where
town is and he pulls out a shotgun yeah
it's back the way you came
that's the trope man don't don't screw
around with people like get off my
property dude my husband likes so
winter's bone i love jennifer lawrence
like the one that she was nominated for
an oscar for my husband always tells
people he's like you know where elisha's
from they're like no i'm like well
here's oklahoma and there's where i'm
from and then my husband's like have you
seen winter's bone and they're like yes
and he's like that's where elisha is
from nice people
look look australia's got you know
they're crazy spiders and you know
kangaroos you see that video where the
kangaroos like banging on the glass they
they used to have rats that were like
climbing into cribs and trying to ebay
so it's a scary place but for whatever
reason the government comes out and
they're like we're going to lock all you
in camps and they're like that's all
right mate so
the reason why is it it actually is a
society that is very like middle class
upper middle class like everybody is
middle class like if you are if you
drive an airport shuttle there you're
like middle class and i have a lot of
friends that are australian and love
them dearly and one of my girlfriends
just became an american citizen by the
way super cool um
she has like family still over there
especially her grandparents and they've
talked about like this upper class much
like in the united states right like you
have these rich elitists that can still
go to mexico and fly their private
planes and send their kids to the 70
grand a year you know private school in
la and pretend like everything's okay
chrissy teigen but
but um it is the lower class there it is
like the blue collar people that are the
ones that are going out and protesting
and and getting their you know what's
handed to them by the cops really brutal
stuff that is disgusting that is not
being covered by media anywhere and it's
kind of like the upper class it's like
oh you know we we got the shot we're
okay and it is the it is the
the poor the underrepresented underdogs
there that are like no enough is enough
and i'm like good for them like if any
of you are watching good for you like
god bless you it's the poor people that
have been predominantly the victims here
they're the ones that are losing a lot
of their money losing their savings
losing their economic uh mobility losing
any kind of economic opportunities
they're the ones absolutely getting
riddled with regulations restrictions
they can't operate a small business
multinational corporations they could be
open when lockdowns are imposed on
everyone else they could conduct
business they of course could afford the
regulations they could afford the extra
taxes they could afford every little
whim of that the government puts on them
because they're working hand in hand
together and working out secret deals
that essentially benefit them and that's
why we're seeing the largest transfer of
wealth and recorded human history
happening right now thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time